people
all right he's taking off on me we are
at the eastbound Barnard from sweet
Applewood
be dead 45. a high-speed chase in
Wisconsin ends in a deadly crash after
the driver refuses to pull over and
rushes off at speeds near 100 miles per
hour it's 88 miles an hour Rose dry snow
traffic
[Music]
the chase began in Cudahy Wisconsin just
south of Milwaukee on March 22nd at the
time a Cudahy police officer attempted
to pull over a vehicle for speeding and
having a headlight out
investigators learned later the driver
was 23 year old Justin Michaela who had
a warrant out for his arrest for
violating parole this guy's on the phone
he's still rolling he he's not putting
it in park it's just a slow roll
officers say Michaela was driving his
girlfriend's vehicle the girlfriend
later told police she was on the phone
as they attempted to pull him over he
called me and he's like oh four minutes
the police behind me I'm like just pull
over like just pull over I don't want my
car to get totaled Dan he's like the
phone's gonna die the phone died
Mitchell Nicole so he was he was on the
phone with you when I initially stopped
him yes okay because I could see him on
speakerphone dash camera video shows
yeah
all right he's taking off on me we are
in the eastbound Barnard from here soon
[Music]
speeds at 45. the Cudahy officer
continues to tail Michaela as he speeds
off he's 88 miles an hour Rose Drive no
traffic
[Music]
meanwhile additional officers join the
chase Boulevard
[Music]
ocean bound
the chase lasts at least three minutes
before officers lose sight of makila
either banged off East on Rawson or west
through the park
all right looks like we've made a lot
size here
still on Chicago or
is crossing we're awesome either banged
off Easton Rawson went West through the
park
the last time I run that curve there
right
10-3
um yeah at least five blocks or not five
blocks because they want three blocks on
me
so foreign
Cudahy officials then call on South
Milwaukee Police Officers for assistance
finding the vehicle can do me a favor
and call over to South Milwaukee there
was a South Milwaukee Squad that was
coming north on Chicago and see if he
saw anything
officer I couldn't hear you
yes just advice about it when they
called and we were checking the area we
have not seen uh the vehicle that they
were pursuing but we are we do have
Squad second area meanwhile officials
work to confirm what type of vehicle
they're searching for dusk it was a
older model sedan possibly a 90 series
um maybe at Toyota
I'm gonna have some pretty decent dash
cam quicker
it was in the rear window you know for
sure the first three was Adam Sandler
foreign
Mazda four-door Sedan blue in color
because the vehicle belonged to
Michaela's girlfriend officers meet up
with her at an Airbnb where she's
staying I'm trying to figure out where
is my card located at you guys were just
literally on the chase with my boyfriend
and he called me saying the police is
behind him I'm like just pull over
what's his name justy Justin what's his
last name uh Michaela
Mazda what 2000 Portage what color uh
like a dark blue do you know your
license plate at all um yes I have it in
my phone
I literally
yes I'm sorry why don't you hang up with
her because she has other calls coming
in okay yes thank you
sorry did he tell you where he was at he
he told me he was four minutes I heard
polices and I heard my car I heard it
coming from the same way
did he tell you where he was though
no he just told me I'm four minutes from
here I'm four minutes from here
50 says thus we have contacts with the
registered owner officers explained they
do not have her vehicle or know where
her boyfriend is yep that's the plate
that we have to so unfortunately we
don't have your boyfriend or the vehicle
right now
um the best thing he can possibly do is
you know come and talk to us
just love my car I just bought my car
it's my first car I was looking for him
right now I just want my car all right
do you have your do you have your your
boyfriend's like
does he does he have a iPhone at all are
you able to track his phone no I have uh
I have his phone number but it's just
going straight to voicemail straight to
voicemail straight to voicemail I don't
know why we getting the pursuit with my
car is my first car my first car
Michaela's girlfriend tells officers she
asked her boyfriend to pull over while
speaking to him on the phone he called
me and he's like I'm four minutes the
police behind me I'm like just pull over
like just pull over I don't want my car
to get totaled then he's like the
phone's gonna die the phone that I've
been trying to call so he was he was on
the phone with you when I initially
stopped him yes okay because I could see
him on speakerphone
oh so you stopped them oh okay yes he
was on the phone with me
and I'm like just pull over like just
pull over you're gonna make it worser
than what it is just pull over
phone went dead I really just want my
car it's my first car so I think I
really have right now my son all right
but we we can't really do anything for
you with the car right now you gave him
permission to use it yes and then he
decided to take off so I guess in the
future he probably doesn't use a car no
no but I'm sorry sorry I'm at the point
where if y'all take him that's that's
okay I just run my car no because you
don't do that type of stuff it's
somebody's car like you
you don't do that I don't got nothing on
my name nothing like nothing
I understand that
but like I said I just don't want it to
escalate anything where anybody would
get hurt yes sir
officials then ask why Michaela may have
run off did he tell you why he why he
wasn't going to stop for me no I just
said just pull over I know he got some
other stuff going on with his name but
I'm like it might not be that deep like
just pull over well really I just really
care about my car like I don't need you
to total my car trying to run from the
police pull over
he he the phone went dead like I heard
like over this way so I went around like
let me see if I can find find the police
this car but it was too everywhere I
don't know where I moved yet so I didn't
want to go too far from the Airbnb
because my baby is in their sleep yeah
is there a reason why he wouldn't stop
for me
some stuff like I think he got like some
stuff on his name or something some
warrants some warrants so maybe that's
why he didn't want to stop but I told
him you could just stop I know when we
got pulled over
um not too long ago the police was okay
like they they let him up like maybe if
you just talk to him or something I
don't think you're the one is that big
maybe go win for a couple months type of
warrant but it's like okay that's okay
like
okay
all right I appreciate you being really
Cooperative with us this goes a long way
all right and I will do everything in my
power to to you know get your car back
to you okay okay but in the next half
half hour the vehicle is discovered in
South Milwaukee after crashing over an
embankment and landing in the water
below
look away if you don't want to be in the
photo here
can you do me a favor and send a photo
of the driver
yourself
thank you so much
officials say Michaela was killed in the
crash reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie